[Music]  hey Victor yeah yeah oh no here we go  since I can remember I've wanted to  dance he opened a paddy I will take you  to this dance school and you will become  the greatest dancer ever you're  unbelievable  dance school in Paris are you the  caretaker yes and you can stay with me  until you get on your feet  every girl in this room has a chance to  dance in my new ballet starting tomorrow  we'll have an audition can you dance yes  at least I think I can yeah huh who is  that Rudy I love him he's so blond you  can work as hard as you like  but you will always be nothing so how do  I get that part because you have  something she can only dream of passion  in you get that part do you hear me I  have no idea why you're happy but it is  great  we should never give up on our dreams  I know you're ready  [Music]  hello mr. boost I've just taken away  your computer privileges yes sir it's  time for you to stop this unhealthy  behavior you can't